this is a CBS News special report I'm 22
couple in New York the Labor Department
has just released the latest weekly
unemployment report and CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger has
those numbers Jill good morning this has
become something of a grim Thursday
ritual for us and the nation what is the
new number and what does it tell us an
additional 2.4 million americans filed
for unemployment benefits and that
brings us to almost amazingly 40 million
about 39 million americans also of note
in this report we see the people who are
receiving their benefits already that
number is at 25 million right now and
that really drives with some new
information from the Census Bureau just
released yesterday Tony where we saw
that about 47% of Americans say that
they have lost some household income a
startling number another federal data
point that came in this week the
Congressional Budget Office and
nonpartisan research group issued some
projections for this year and next what
do they show well what we're looking at
is a longer recovery and that is quite
clear CBO says that the US economy will
not recover to where it was at the end
of last year for another two years
probably in fact as of the end of 2021
the US economy will be 1.6 percent
smaller than it was in December of 2019
CBO also believes the unemployment rate
will remain above 15% through September
it is also likely to be above 9% by the
end of 2021 Tony and that is remarkable
that is just one percentage point below
where it was at the worst of the Great
Recession
Wow Jill Schlesinger thank you very much
that puts it all in perspective the
headline again more than two million
additional jobless claims cumulative
claims now in the nine weeks since the
coronavirus economic crisis began now on
the order of the entire population of
California almost 40 million are canned
our coverage will continue on our
24-hour streaming network at CBS n and
you can watch it at CBS news.com or on
the CBS News app